[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 1: Good luck
from Hoagie Haven.
Go Tigers!
SUBJECT 2: Hey,
good luck on finals.
Hope you do well.
SUBJECT 3: I want to
wish all the students
at Princeton University
good luck on your tests.
SUBJECT 4: Hi.
I'm Mayor Liz Lempert.
And I'm here to wish all
of you the best of luck
on your finals.
Just remember you're
really, really smart.
So I'm sure you're
going to do well.
Stay hydrated and get
a good night's sleep.
SUBJECT 5: Study hard!
SUBJECT 6: I wish
you all the best.
I know your hard
work will pay off.
So good luck on your exam.
SUBJECT 7: Hi, Princeton
University students.
Just want to wish you guys
well from Jammin' Crepes.
A crepe a day will
keep all the F's away.
Best of luck.
SUBJECT 8: Good luck on
your finals from Wawa.
SUBJECT 9: Hi, from your
friends at the Princeton Garden
Theatre, we'd like to wish you
good luck in all your finals.
SUBJECT 10: Hi, everybody.
I know this is a really,
really stressful time for you
all as you're
preparing for finals.
I just want to let
you know that in life
and in career,
managing your stress
is going to be so important.
So please to take care of
business, take care of yourself
first.
Eat healthy, exercise,
try and weave
in some time for
relaxation and rest.
Even as stressful
as it is right now,
these deadlines
will come and go.
But you want to take
care of yourself,
because you're in this
for the long haul.
SUBJECT 11: Hi,
Princeton students.
This is Princeton Pi.
We wish you luck on
your exams this week.
And we hope that you
eat a lot of pizza
during your study groups.
And again, thank you
from Princeton Pi
and supporting you,
and good luck.
SUBJECT 12: Hi.
How are you doing?
I just want to wish all
the students of Princeton
University good luck, and
keep up the hard work.
I've worked here
for five, six years.
I see how hard you guys work
and how much effort you put in.
And I just wish you
the best of luck
with all of your endeavors,
and a great new year.
SUBJECT 13: Hi, students.
It's Jen.
Just want to wish you good
luck with your exams, and let
you know that DPS
fully supports you.
SUBJECT 14: Just want to say
good luck to the Princeton
University students.
All right!
SUBJECT 15: I would like
to wish you, the students,
the best on your exams.
Be confident.
You were chosen out of
thousands to be here.
This university believes
in you, as I do too.
Stay strong, stay
focused, and continue
to support each other
and your dreams.
SUBJECT 16: Hi, everyone.
This is Coach King.
I just wanted to wish you
good luck on your finals.
As a alum, I've been there.
I've done that.
And I know you can too.
So good luck.